[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wristing it around the wall in the tampa
and far
side to near lightning reverse it near
side to far but give it away
bailey couldn't hold his own turnover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
intake
that's chris king long time play-by-play
voice for the islanders radio
network and chris joins us
love the enthusiasm chris uh
what do you hear when you hear yourself
that night uh last night dan not much of
anything and that's the challenge for me
i think in those situations i realize
you know we have the oldest and loudest
building
in the national hockey league and as you
heard there if i don't get that call out
they're gonna crush me and they did
uh so i did my best to get it out but i
realized i got to try to take it to a
level above them and
unfortunately i guess for me when i try
to go to that level uh my voice cracks
and it's not something i can control it
just kind of happens but
i think last night was the most i've
ever been buried by a crowd in uh
you know 27 years of doing islanders
radio now with the coliseum
now what do you mean buried by as far as
the noise
yeah just the noise level itself was
that loud normally i can get the call
out you can hear the call but i think i
get the word goal out and then kind of
everything after that is just
in the wash of the euphoria of the crowd
and you can just hear the stomping going
on all around me
uh in every direction and it really does
drown me out to an extent that really
hadn't happened before
where is the crowd in proximity to where
you're broadcasting from
yeah right now we're back in the
traditional press box in the regular
season we were kind of down on the
concourse so it's it's
uh mostly directly below me and kind of
all around me
except for the above position but again
in the coliseum
the ceiling is so low because it's
nearly a 50 year old building
so there's just no place for the sound
to go so it immediately bounces off the
roof and comes
right back into our booth in the press
box and
i i didn't know if they were banging on
you know any part of the broadcast
facility you know where you it felt like
they were right next to you
it did feel that way and that banging
part when i listened to it back that's
something i've never heard before either
so i'm just assuming it's stomping going
on in general
uh but you know this is a passionate
islander crowd that's always been that
way and
i think dan it's just gone to another
level uh because of the nostalgia of it
you know this is their final season
at nassau veterans memorial coliseum the
place they've called home essentially
for nearly 50 years now and
every time they win a game it at least
gives you the possibility that there
will be future games still to come
in that building and that was the case
last night now you say they not we
yeah i mean i i guess i kind of go back
and forth but i try to stay away from
that we thing i am an employee of the
new york islanders i have followed the
team since day one i was 11 years old
when they arrived on long island here in
1972 but but i try to stay to the va as
opposed to the wii
yes but you know that if you don't win
game seven
that that was the last game
yeah you know it's the last playoff game
and again this is the little caveat to
the whole thing dan is that their new
building ubs arena at belmont park
is scheduled to open in november so the
nhl is planning on starting next season
maybe mid-october
so if that building opens in early
november i think it'll be the end for
the coliseum if they don't win game
seven
tomorrow night in tampa but if that
building won't open till the end of
november
will the islanders be willing to play
you know up to six weeks on the road
just to make sure that the first home
game's in the new arena so again we've
kind of gone down this path before with
the coliseum
where they thought they had closed it
tight in 25th 2015 only to come back in
so i do still give the possibility that
there could be some early regular season
games there next season
if the new building isn't done in time
to open up
my first professional hockey game that i
saw now i saw the cincinnati stingers
play but i was there
when uh you had ken morrow's goal at the
garden
so that's my first professional hockey
game
and i'm with an islanders fan i was
working at cnn
and we're behind the glass and he says
i'm just gonna let you know not all
hockey games are like this
and and that was like watching billy
smith
like just slash p like he was just don't
even think about coming in here i'm
gonna i'm gonna be
and so much talent was on the ice then
and i remember covering i the islanders
are the most professional team i ever
covered
with flatley and lafontaine bossie
trottier and you know al arbour they
they
they were great people to a young
reporter and i never forgot that
that uh you know the islanders knew they
were being passed by
you know gretzky's edmonton oilers but
what a classy
group of people there i can't say the
same about the nassau coliseum
chris because it hasn't it i don't think
it was nice
back when it was new it has a certain
charm dan
and as long as it's your barn that's all
it is the loudest building in the league
that the fans have taken it to a
different level in this year's playoffs
it's not just cheering it's stomping
it's serenading it's songs it's
chance it's you know barry trotz has his
name cheered by
13 000 people non-stop when he takes the
ice every night what head coach
here's barry barry barry on his way to
the bench things like that and there's a
song for josh bailey that they sing
every single night so they do things
that are unique uh not only in the nhl
but in almost all sports and you know
it's kind of going out the way it needs
to with this incredible run that
they hope continues for a couple more
games in the cup final he's chris king
the long time play by play voice for the
islanders radio network you get
recognized for your voice
yes i do i think that's more so than my
face obviously with uh my
most of my career being uh particularly
in radio so that's the thing that most
people uh you know
uh mentioned to me and i've had a lot of
instances where maybe i'm standing in
line somewhere at a deli waiting to make
my order or something and people are
looking at me and don't say anything and
then when i
place my order everybody goes oh you're
kinger so it is the voice a lot more
than the face
for a long time radio man yeah but i
think it's kind of tacky that you'll go
i'll take a pastrami on white bread
witches
[Applause]
well i do get that a lot it's pretty
funny like they want me to do the order
in that voice and obviously i'm not that
way around the clock
but you know if the deli man asked for
the order to be in classic uh chris king
fashion we can go there could you
recreate that call
last night oh you know and again it's
interesting damn because i
listen back to it i can't hear too much
of it so i mean i could try to recreate
it for you so that the folks could
actually hear it but uh if you want me
to go there i would give it a shot
all right here we go do we let let's
play the original just to let people
know
yeah let me hear it because i can't hear
much of it yeah like you don't even know
what you said probably
okay so here it is here's the call last
night between the islanders
and their uh their game six win letty
wrists it in around the wall in the
tampa and far side to near lightning
reverse it nearside to far but give it
away
bailey couldn't hold his own turnover
and take
[Applause]
chris chris i i don't know i think
you'll pull a groin i
i i like i you still have to give us
game seven here so
you went you went from four to eleven
you blew past
ten you went right to 11 there yeah i
did it and you know what i call it dan
you'll appreciate this i call it the
peter
peter brady syndrome of course you know
one of the most famous brady bunch
episodes is when peter has to sing and
you know it's time to change and the
voice kind of takes off
so that's my peter brady moment but uh
yeah it happened pretty quickly there
but
again kudos to the coliseum fans for
burying most of that uh in the wash
uh set the scene for game seven wow uh
you know just been an incredible series
dan
obviously there's been a couple of 2-1
games there's been an eight-nothing loss
for the islanders down in tampa in game
five but uh
you know what i gotta think a little bit
of the momentum on is on the side of the
islanders right now is tampa blew a
two-nothing lead in that game six we
don't know the status of nikita kucherov
you know one of their best players who
played only one shift last night
before leaving the game so if they don't
have him that's a big problem and the
barry trotz factor is something that
really has to be considered back in 2018
barry's capitals were down 3-2 to the
lightning much like the islanders were
in this series
they won game six at home they went to
tampa and they won game seven
four to nothing and then went on to win
their first stanley cup in franchise
history so barry
certainly knows about going into emily
arena and winning a big game seven and
then taking it to the next step
in the following series so uh you know i
think the islanders are confident
if you look at what they've done then on
the road in these playoffs they won two
out of three in pittsburgh they won two
out of three in boston they took game
one down in tampa so they're not afraid
of the road environment at all
but the lightning also have to say hey
look they haven't lightning
lost back-to-back games in any point of
the playoffs last year or this year so
that's going to be their biggest
you know confidence booster is nobody
has knocked them off in back-to-back
games in two years now
in the stanley cup playoffs rest your
voice chris
i will dan i will thank you thank you
bud
thanks for having me that's uh chris
king they call him the kinger
long time play-by-play voice for the
islanders radio network